we probably don't look at movies and
shows this way often enough when we do
we notice some pretty fascinating things
about some of our favorite characters
what do these black panther characters
first and last lines tell us the World's
Gonna find out exactly who we are number
one Michael B Jordan delivers an
intimidating villain in his performance
of killmonger his first line arrives at
a museum in London I'm just checking out
these artifacts they tell me you're the
expert in our first moment meeting
killmonger we're given a quick first
impression that could read as a proud
cunning powerful and knowledgeable
person killmonger's character seems to
remain steady throughout the movie all
the way to his last moments his last
line comes in a powerful and defiant
moment when he braces himself with the
power of His ancestors just bury me in
the ocean
but my ancestors that jump from the
ships they knew death was better than
bondage and with that killmonger leaves
t'challa much to think on that's how you
built that trust you know I'm saying
that type of that type of chemistry that
bond that makes you feel like you could
do anything number two t'challa is
brought To Us by Chadwick Boseman
introducing himself to us through his
first lines
out as quickly as possible it is in this
scene that we are also introduced to
Okoye in this early scene t'challa might
not yet have developed an appreciation
for the power of teamwork and maybe
we're meant to get a feeling for this
through his opting to go It Alone
t'challa's character seems to carry a
lone wolf or a hot shot Outlook in
earlier parts of the story but by the
time t'challa's last line is delivered
some big changes have happened and it's
evident he is a transformed character I
think he's the the combination of of the
past and present or past in the future
actually t'challa delivers his last
lines in one of the final scenes of the
film where he addresses the uh and as
someone who has a better understanding
of the meaning of teamwork and
Leadership the first time in our history
we will be sharing our knowledge and
resources with the outside world number
three from the moment we meet her Nakia
seems to be a character of constant
momentum actor Lupita Nyong'o delivers
her first line to us in a scene where
Nakia and t'challa work together to
rescue people who have been kidnapped by
a military group this one's just a boy
she got kidnapped as well it is also in
this moment that we are introduced to
one of the first female characters in
Black Panther who shares some fan
favorite moments with Okoye in the film
we really like each other we had really
good chemistry over the course of the
story we become privy to t'challa's
admiration for Nakia as a kind person
and a skilled spy for wakanda Nakia
seems to be a character of fierce
loyalty with a strong drive to do the
right thing her last line pretty much
sums it up it was my duty to fight for
what I love I should have
number four akoye emanates power from
the moment we meet her actor deny
Guerrera expertly conveys this Authority
in okoya's belief and simple first line
which comes to US during the action of
flying over a military Convoy with
t'challa my prince
coming up on them now not much to go
with for establishing your character but
we think deny made quick work of it
while her opening lines might only get
our imaginations going with what this
character is capable of the rest of the
story lets us see it unfold akoya is a
character of trust and dedication and it
carries through to her last scene where
she has been forced to fight against
wakabi who has sided with killmonger in
the fight for the wakandan throne
without the question number five Daniel
kaluya's performance brings us the
conflicted wakabi he begins with his
first line in a friendly exchange with
t'challa who is describing his
enthusiasm for a healthy young wakandan
Rhino by the name of M20 wakabi
expresses interest and concern over
t'challa's and nikia's prior and
potentially future relationship I see
Nakia is Big you guys going to work it
out
this knowledge of intimate details and
close friendly concern sets us up for a
shock when wakabi sides with killmonger
during his hostile takeover of the
throne but it seems to be revealed in
the final chapter of the film that
wakabi was driven by a sense of Duty and
the rules to act out against his
personal preferences this is brought to
light when okoya his romantic partner
offers him the chance to surrender
before the two are forced to fight each
other wakabi hesitates but then delivers
his last line did you kill me my love
before effectively ending the battle
with his surrender I think it was really
important for me that Arc ended in that
way because it I felt it was honest and
I think it's needed number six
t'challa's brilliant younger sister is
played by actor Leticia Wright who
brings us a smart and energetic
performance of shuri did he freeze
like an antelope in headlights
it seems the two are very close and
friendly as she teases her older brother
after learning he loses his cool during
a rescue mission with Nikia and okoya
despite her driven intellect she shows
us a playful and immature side during
her first line it just came really
really easy he's a soul brother like
most of the royal wakandan family Cherie
goes through some big changes throughout
the movie her last line might indicate
to us she understands she can have a
great impact with little effort she
shows this when she tells the kids on
the Oakland basketball court where the
spaceship has come from with her simple
last line
number seven Baku comes across as an
antagonist for our Royal wakandan Heroes
and actor Winston Duke handles this
nuanced task with finesse mbaku openly
vies for the throne using the ancient
challenge of ritual combat with his
first lines it's challenge day we have
watched a listen from the mountain we
later see that what we might have
mistaken for a dislike of t'challa and
his family is actually a great and
driven care for wakanda and its people
they love you if they love you that's
you Baku embodies this when he commits
his Warrior to the final battle with his
last line
number eight and jobu's impact on the
story was fundamental the film opens
with his first lines I mean the twins
pulling up right here we're leaving this
car behind okay we're coming we later
learn that in jobu is killmonger's
father that killmonger has blamed
t'challa for his death and it might even
seem that in jobu's actions are at the
root of the conflict he may have a
traumatic effect he appears to
killmonger in a vision where he elicits
reconsideration from killmonger with his
last line I should have taken you back
long ago instead we are both abandoned
here number nine Forest Whitaker lends
his acting chops to Black Panther in the
role of Zuri we immediately know that
Zuri is an official and plays an
important role in facilitating the
rituals of wakanda with his first line
we later learned he has greatly
influenced the history of wakanda as
well having effectively set the stage
for killmonger and t'challa's conflict I
was so excited about what was actually
occurring he expresses remorse for his
misdoings in his last line I am the
cause of your father's day not here
take me number 10. t'chaka is the
reigning king of wakando and actor John
Connie lends his expertise to the role
t'chaka first appears as the Black
Panther and asserts himself as a leader
with his first line leave us tachaka was
a dedicated leader who strove to bring
about the best for the wakandans even if
not given enough time we see this in his
last line I chose my people
I chose wakanda our future depending
well they can be short can really give
us some strong hints about the journeys
of our favorite characters we think it's
a fun way to look at a movie or a show
what do you think what are some of your
favorite first and last line
combinations let us know in the comments
below